hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
ps.l2-3.9.2 ensure that organizational
systems containing cui are protected
during and after Personnel actions such
as terminations and transfers
[Music]
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist spout and 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance solution where we can
help you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so on this control we really dive a
little deeper into your operational
standard operating procedures okay that
is written policies that are in place
which guide and dictate Behavior around
certain events in this case the event is
termination of an employee a sensitive
event for any company but even more so
when you have controlled unclassified
information involved what the assessors
are really after here is do you have a
formal written process is your team
trained in it and can you prove that the
process is in place and working all very
important let's take a look at exactly
what the assessors want to see on this
one a couple assessment points here one
determine if a policy and or process for
terminating system access and any
credentials coincide with Personnel
actions is established and again a
little bit of complex one here if we're
going to give uh sort of an example we
would write what our process is right so
prior determination or at the time of
termination whichever comes first and it
ticket is put into the system to
immediately revoke all system access and
take immediate control and restrict
access to any connected devices which
may contain cui so again
we're just describing our procedures
there next assessment point determinive
system access and credentials are
terminated consistent with personal
Personnel actions such as termination or
transfer this is implemented per hr
termination policy so again
straightforward gotta have an HR
termination policy next one is determine
if system is protected during and after
Personnel transfer actions so remember
this may not be a termination it may be
a transfer they may be taking on
different job roles so they may not need
access to the rest of what they have
before again if we were to answer this
we'd say hey terminations are critical
severity events and the highest level
I.T Personnel taking media action to
secure organizational assets at the
first notification of termination for HR
policy the same goes for transfers so
again we sort of copy paste that one a
little bit but we also again highlight
the fact that transfers are treated the
same way
so hey at on-call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfars nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped into their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day we teach you how
to level up and be a proper on-call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that is what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc complianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below to get links that can help
you right now if you love the content
we're putting out here for you help us
out with a big thumbs up on that like
button or even better smash the
Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance runs rolled out I'm gonna
pause right there because let me tell
you what if you haven't subscribed to
our Channel
Now's the Time the heavens are raining
down and it's time to do your duty click
that like button click that subscribe
button we put this content out here for
free for you guys and you know what
there's always so much evolving and
changing when it comes to compliance and
keeping defense contractors where they
need to be in the know I want you to be
the first one to get that information so
if you haven't subscribed to our Channel
yet hit that subscribe button I think
you'll really love it until the next
compliance tip my friend stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance and
I'll see you on the next one
foreign
[Music]